جيرارد يحتفلوا بالكريسماس مع صلاح وعريضه
ارجنتينيه للفرنسيين كفوا عن البكاء يشغل
في عالم المستديره هذه الاخبار وغيرها
نقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
احتفل اسطوره ليفربول ستيفن جيرارد بعيد
الميلاد مع ابنه الصغير ليو في منزلهما
سوره الاحزاب خطفت الانظار لوجود النجم
المصري محمد صلاح في الخلفيه على الحائط
في ناس اثناء نشر محمد صلاح صوره برفقه
عائله وهم يرتدون ازياء من وحي الكريسماس
رفقه مكه وخيان وامك وشاهد الصوره على
تويتر اكثر من 36 مليون شخص حتى موعد
كتابه هذا الخبر
وقع اكثر من 500,000 شخص على عريضه عبر
الانترنت اطلقت من الارجنتين تطالب فرنسا
ضد توقف عن البكاء بعد هزيمتها في نهائي
مونديال قطر
العريضه منذ انفذنا لم يتوقف الفرنسيون عن
البكاء والشكوه ولا يقبلون ان الارجنتين
هي بطله العالم
تجمع افراد اسره اسطوره كره القدم
البرازيليه بيليف في مستشفى البرت
اينشتاين حيث يطلب علاجه مولات منذ اواخر
نوفمبر الماضيه وقال الاطباء خلال الاسبوع
الماضي ان مرض السرطان الذي يعاني منه
بيليه تطور وهو ما يتطلب رعايه تتعلق
بقصور في وظائف الكلى والقلب